c'était tout à l'heure j'avais très très
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas entendu
des questions au Premier ministre qui ce
qui est de la joute hebdomadaire au
Parlement ici avec un tel consensus
entre le gouvernement et l'opposition
touche unis pour soutenir l'Ukraine et
pour saluer l'arrivée du président
zenenski le chef de l'opposition en
kirstamer a même salué le président
zeninski comme un symbole de
d'une héroïsme du peuple ukrainien face
à l'agression Russey le président
zenkinski qui s'apprête à parler dans
devant les Chambres les deux chambres du
Parlement réunies dans le hall de
Westminster ce qui est un grand honneur
pour un chef d'État étranger à savoir
que le dernier à s'adresser ainsi dans
le hall de Westminster de du Parlement
était le président Obama avant lui
Nelson Mandela et c'est là bien sûr que
la reine a été veillée par les
Britanniques avant d'être enterré donc
c'est véritablement la preuve que le le
menu tient à montrer le soutien à
l'Ukraine de d'une grande façon de la
façon la plus avec tous les honneurs
ainsi donc le président zenenski va
s'exprimer ensuite le Premier ministre
et le président iron voir s'entraîner
les soldats Ukrainiens dans dans le sud
de l'Angleterre autour de southbory et
donc s'entraîner aux chars
au short challenger 2 dont 14 vont être
envoyés en Ukraine d'ici la fin du mois
de mars donc c'est là que c'est là que
ça va c'est des choses vont se dérouler
cet après-midi après bien sûr l'audience
avec le roi le président zeneski qui ira
après avoir quitté le Parlement jusqu'au
Palace de jusqu'au palais de Buckingham
le président
[Musique]